bitcoin has been taking over the world
and literally countries are competing
now for bitcoin miners to be within
their jurisdictions what am i talking
about well the russian ministry of
economic development is now advocating
to give minors of bitcoin lower
electricity taxes that's right they're
going to try to use taxation as a carrot
as an incentive to get bitcoin miners to
go to russia use their power and
actually mine the digital currency
within their borders it's pretty
interesting why because we know that the
hash rate of bitcoin there's been a
whole bunch of movement china kicking
out over 60 of the bitcoin hash rate
over the last 12 months and those miners
all looking for a new home we know the
united states has been a big beneficiary
texas alone as a state within the united
states now has about 10 percent of the
global hash rate in the bitcoin network
but russia making a big big buying to
get more and more those bitcoin miners
to join their country using taxation
that's an incentive we can see here hash
rate by country that big change ladies
and gentlemen all because china decided
to kick out a number of those miners now
a place like russia has this really
interesting dichotomy that they now have
to break down
is crypto a currency is it a foreign
currency is it something that should be
regulated is it something that should be
banned this is all being decided right
now within the country not only is
russia going to go ahead and actually
represent that bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies are legal within the
country that there's regulatory
frameworks they can use they're now
going to use that taxation as an
incentive to go ahead and get people to
move there and actually start mining now
this isn't the first time we've seen a
country or a state do something like
this the state of kentucky here in the
united states they actually signed a
bill that had tax breaks for crypto
miners that type of bill is really
important again using taxation not as a
weapon but as an incentive that's senate
bill 255 extended the commonwealth's
clean energy focused incentives to
minors who invest at least one million
dollars in equipment and the house bill
230 similarly offers miners a series of
sales and excise tax breaks what we are
watching is a global competition for
bitcoiners and bitcoin miners everyone's
gonna want them to come to their
jurisdiction taxation can be either a
carrot or a stick and seeing places like
kentucky and russia use it as that
incentive is really interesting i expect
that every single country every single
state around the world is going to
eventually have to consider should we
give tax breaks to these people who are
creating economic prosperity jobs and
innovation or should we continue to be
abrasive to this fast growing changing
industry those that work closely with
the bitcoin industry are likely to be
better suited in the future and so
expect more and more tax breaks expect
better and better treatment there's a
global competition underway if you want
bitcoiners and bitcoin miners to move to
your jurisdiction start actually
incentivizing them to do it